Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Voi sapete chi è questa persona?
Sì, no?
Questa persona è Leonard Nimoy!
Chi è Leonard Nimoy? Vai!
È Spock! Brava!
Quello lì è il Dottor Spock,
probabilmente nessuno di voi
lo aveva riconosciuto, forse solo lei:
quando però vi ho detto
che è il dottor Spock...
Chi è che conosce il Dott Spock?
Un sacco di persone!
Lui è un attore, un artista,
è una persona che...
non è un lavoro vero, fare l’artista
non è proprio una cosa...
cioè, non è che ci paghi
il mutuo di casa.
Invece un lavoro vero
è un lavoro dove sei laureato,
sei un ingegnere, sei medico,
sei avvocato.
Sapete chi è questa persona?
Lei ha un lavoro vero,
lei è un pilota militare, un'astronauta.
È Samantha Cristoforetti,
conosce 5 lingue , 2 lauree.
In questo momento è in orbita,
e il problema con Leonard,
quello di prima,
è che l’anno scorso è morto,
per cui quello che è successo
è che lei in orbita
ha fatto questo gesto,
che è il saluto di Star Trek,
e ha indossato la maglietta di Star Trek.
Ed effettivamente, se ci pensate bene
lei è in orbita perché, come voi,
lei è stata ispirata
dal film di Star Trek.
Voi sarete stati ispirati
da un altro libro,
da un’altra cosa,
da qualsiasi altra cosa
che ha scritto un sognatore,
e un sacco di gente si è sbattuta
per costruire l’astronave
su cui lei è adesso,
perché quella lì è la stazione spaziale,
lei è fisicamente in orbita,
e quella lì è veramente
la curvatura della Terra.
Lei probabilmente è astronauta
perché voleva fare come Star Trek:
è andata nello spazio,
voleva esplorare lo spazio,
come voi avete fatto le vostre scelte
dopo che avete visto un film,
avete letto un libro, avete fatto
qualcosa che vi ha ispirato.
Per cui è vero che gli ingegneri,
quella gente lì, sono importanti,
hanno un lavoro serio;
ma anche i sognatori,
anche quelli che inventano cose,
pur non facendole fisicamente,
sono importanti, perché sono loro
che ispirano il futuro.
E poi, altrettanto importante,
c’è un sacco di gente che il futuro
lo inventa per davvero.
Per cui - io faccio computer grafica -
se volessi fare medicina
il mio problema sarebbe che
ho un sacco di anni di storia da studiare,
tantissimi, un sacco di libri,
un sacco di cose...
Se volessi fare architettura,
- un altro lavoro serio -
non è che mi va tanto meglio,
perché anche li ho un sacco
di anni da studiare.
Se volessi fare ingegneria,
wow, lì ancora peggio.
Fotografia mi va un po' meglio,
perché fotografia ho 2/300 anni,
quindi mi va abbastanza bene.
Se voglio fare invece
computer grafica... ieri,
perché la computer grafica è nata ieri
quindi si studia veramente poco:
fatto computer grafica!
All’inizio, la forma
di chi faceva CG è questa,
per cui quando uno dice
io faccio Computer Grafica
la seconda domanda
che ti viene detta è:
ma io ho un problema
con Word, me lo sistemi?
NO! Io non lo so usare, word.
Impossibile, tu sei un genio!
Perché la gente ha in mente
quella roba lì,
nel senso, la gente ha in mente
quello lì dietro un computer,
che fa delle cose incredibili
in uno scantinato,
non parla con nessuno,
nessuno sa cosa faccia,
Poi però ad un certo punto
è uscito questo film al cinema,
che hanno visto
probabilmente 7 persone.
In sala lo ha visto qualcuno?
...e sono tutte presenti,
quindi è un momento storico.
È un momento storico.
(Applausi)
Questo film era la prima volta al mondo
in cui si usava la computer grafica
e la usavano degli artisti
per fare delle cose
che prima facevano soltanto ingegneri
o altra gente cervellona.
Però la gente non le aveva capite bene,
allora ci ha pensato la Pixar
e ha fatto questo.
Chi ha visto Toy Story?
Da li si è capito praticamente
che la CG non solo poteva fare soldi
ma poteva raccontare un sacco di storie,
che la tecnologia
non era più così complicata
e che gli artisti, finalmente,
potevano usare la computer grafica
al pari di una penna.
Quindi da quel punto - ora facciamo
un piccolo corso di computer grafica.
Quello che fa un artista
di computer grafica, normalmente,
è aprire il suo computer,
aprire Maya che è un software
come gli altri, 3D Studio Max o altri,
schiaccia un bottone con scritto Create,
dopo questo bottone schiaccia
Polygon, Cube e Muovi Vertice
- sono comandi veri del software;
lo rifà un milione di volte,
tutto il giorno rifà questa cosa,
e alla fine ottiene questo.
Fico.
Lo rifà ancora un sacco
di volte tutto il giorno,
magari anche un paio di settimane,
e alla fine voi vedete questo,
perché realizza l’astronave di Star Trek.
Nei film li realizzano così,
muovendo vertici...
Ma la cosa più interessante
è che c’è un sacco di gente
che studia le onde gravitazionali,
i buchi neri, i motori a curvatura,
il teletrasporto, vuole andare su Marte,
proprio perché è stata ispirata
da questa cosa qua,
perché un sognatore
ha realizzato questo film.
Voi siete già andati su Marte,
avete già visto The Martian
o un sacco di film
che vi hanno descritto Marte.
Voi ci siete già stati.
Tutte le missioni che adesso
andranno su Marte per voi sarà...
Vabbè, normale, andiamo su Marte...
Per fare questo, vedete,
ci sono un sacco di film che vi ispirano
continuamente, ogni giorno.
Un sacco di sognatori, un sacco di gente
lavora a delle cose che probabilmente
altre persone realizzeranno.
Io ho la fortuna
di lavorare in una scuola
dove ne coltiviamo
un sacco, di questi sognatori.
Oltre a spiegargli la Computer Grafica,
per spiegarglielo chiaramente
che tutto è possibile,
quello che facciamo
è portarli lì, nel niente,
nel deserto tra Utah e la California.
Prendiamo dei ragazzi che hanno
più o meno tra i 20-25 anni,
e dopo il corso
li abbandoniamo lì in mezzo,
con 10 jeep, e gli diciamo:
fai quello che vuoi, tutto è possibile,
vuoi andare da qualche parte? Vacci!
Vuoi andare lì in mezzo? Vai!
Vuoi andare a vedere con 7 auto
cosa c’è nel niente? Vuoi farlo? Fallo!
Parti e vai, perché lo puoi fare,
è possibile.
Se io adesso prendessi
una bacchetta magica
e vi riportassi indietro,
magari qualcuno di voi
ha più di 40 anni, io ho 40 anni,
per cui se mi potessero dare
una bacchetta magica
e rimettermi a 15 anni,
se io volessi fare l’astronauta
probabilmente adesso sarei in orbita,
sicuro al 100%.
Chi è di voi che è convinto
che se lo rimetto a 15 anni
cambia drasticamente la propria vita?
Solo io? Due? Vabbè, solo noi quattro?
Tutti gli altri, avete avuto
la vita perfetta?
Beh, fantastico!
Quello che dobbiamo spiegare ai ragazzi
è questa cosa, renderli consapevoli,
non a 40 anni, del fatto
che puoi cambiare la vita
ma farlo adesso,
in questo istante esatto.
Dirgli che tutto è possibile.
Per esempio, guardate
questo panorama incredibile.
Cosa notate in questo
panorama incredibile?
Quella stella?
Quella non è una stella.
Questa fotografia qui
l’ha fatta Curiosity su Marte.
Quello è Marte e quella stella,
quel pixel che c’è là in mezzo è la Terra.
Noi siamo su quel pixel lì.
Quindi tutti i casini che fate
- io faccio così perché non vi vedo -
tutti i casini che fate,
le guerre, i problemi,
il fatto del petrolio, mille casini,
- quello lì.
Da Marte è incredibile,
tutto si ridimensiona,
perché Marte è il nostro vicino,
Marte è davvero dietro l’angolo.
Non è un problema arrivare lì,
è un problema arrivare
su Alpha Centauri, in altre galassie,
c’è un sacco di roba nel mezzo.
Possiamo scoprire
cose incredibili.
Chi fa Computer grafica ci è già stato,
avete già visto Star Trek,
tutte quelle robe lì,
dovrebbe vederlo
anche la gente normale,
perché quando vi rendete conto
che siete su quel pixel lì,
potete essere solo due cose:
o sognatori, e inventate il futuro;
o essere ispirati da un sognatore
e lo create veramente, il futuro.
Se siete in mezzo,
state perdendo tempo.
(Applausi)